- Guess who I'm with?
The amazing
Gary Vaynerchuk!
CEO of VaynerMedia
among other things.
Many other things.
- Thank you.
- How's it going?
- It's going really well,
it's great to be here.
This is my 10th South-by
so it's changed quite a bit.
When we used to
do things like this
it would be on
like a small FlipCam.
Now there's very expensive
cameras and rigs and lighting.
A lot of has changed,
a lot's the same,
but I'm very happy to be here.
Hello, everybody
that's in this room.
Thrilled to spend
some time together.
- Awesome.
So you're always part of the
trends, you're forecasting.
What's the thing we're
talking about this year?
What's exciting you?
- Listen, the fact of
the matter is nine years ago,
Twitter exploded here,
and then all of the sudden
South-by had to be this place
where things got launched.
The reality is really, besides
Twitter and Foursquare,
nothing's ever been
launched here, right?
So--
- This is an opening
for you, why don't you
launch something here?
- I think this notion
of like, what's exciting?
The same stuff
that's always been exciting,
which is I'm not
super worried about features
or what's getting
covered the most by the media.
I'm worried about
where consumer attention is
and how do I storytell
natively to that platform
in that environment?
So things that I'm not
excited about are consumer VR.
I do not think
consumer VR is here next week.
I think we,
especially if you're at South-by
in this lounge,
we're excited about it.
We understand the
technology is there.
It's exciting.
But the day when an
American or a human being
spends three, four
hours a day in contact lenses
and lives in a virtual
world is much further away
than the people that are in
that industry wish it to be.
The things that excite me
is that Facebook
ads are underpriced
and Instagram and Snapchat
influencers are underpriced.
And most people just
have opinions about it,
even very bright
people in this room
and the people watching at home,
and there are
very few practitioners
in March 2017 marketing.
And that's what excites
me because when you have lack
of practitionership,
there's ability to exploit
those opportunities
if you're deeply grounded
in those principles.
- [Shira] It's funny because
some people actually think
there was a bubble.
I think there's always gonna be
those case studies or
those circumstances--
- What bubble?
- Well, of like the
influencer marketing bubble.
- Influencer marketing
hasn't even started.
Even though it's a one to three,
on people's best
guesses, billion dollar market,
the reality is is
that influencer marketing
has always been here, right?
John Wayne smoked Lucky Stripes.
Somebody we're
paying attention to
doing something with a
brand is tried and true.
It's just that Instagram
and Snapchat and Facebook
and these platforms are at
such scale of distribution now
and there's no middleman.
NBC and Comcast used
to get the middle price.
Now the platform
is the distribution
and the end user's
getting those economics
directly with the brand.
So we're living
through just the early stages
of that genre, because
that's just tried and true.
That just always has been here.
It just looks a
little bit different
than we saw it 40 years ago.
- Now you're an
influencer, you could say,
but you're also a CEO,
you're an entrepreneur,
you're a businessman.
How do you balance
between your own personal brand
and then being
responsible to a company
and employees and all that?
- [Gary] I run my company.
I'm the CEO of an 800 person
$130 million a year business,
and that takes up all my time.
The GaryVee thing
is my side hustle.
I have a team that records
content in vlog form, we use--
- [Shira] He's right here,
that guy.
- DRock.
- [Shira] Does he just travel with you?
- Yes, DRock is the
person I love the most.
(laughs)
DRock is with me all
the time and it's my hack,
I figured it out.
DRock films, we make a vlog.
In that we have 18 hours worth
of content that's happening.
A lot of those turn
into my Medium posts.
into my meme videos.
A lot of those turn
into my audio podcast.
I don't have time to
build a personal brand.
I don't have time.
I live my life
as an entrepreneur.
And I don't win on
being attractive or funny,
I win on being an
operator and being right
about things that are happening,
and that's just
my day-to-day life
and then we produce it at home.
But I spend all my
time running my company.
When I do public speaking,
that's business
development for VaynerMedia.
It's a lot more fun
to get a $3 million scope
doing a keynote at the ANA
than being part
of an RFP process.
That's just smart business.
I think being an influencer...
First of all, 99% of people
that say they're in an
influencer in their
Instagram account
are full of shit,
and for the 1%--
- [Shira] Well don't put that
on your Instagram account.
Like, I'm an influencer.
- Many do.
(Shira laughs)
And then I think
the ones that like,
being in influencer means that
you're bring value to people
as a person living
and creating content
through these platforms that
people are paying attention to.
And so you've gotta
have a lot of talent
to actually win that.
For every Logan Paul,
who I see in the background,
there are 8,000,
80,000, 800,000 people
that aspire to make
videos and pictures on Instagram
and make a living out of it,
and the reality is
they're not interesting enough
or smart enough
or talented enough.
So it's just supply and demand
of are you able to
have somebody's attention.
- And what is
someone supposed to do
if they don't have
a person to run around
following them on a camera?
- [Gary] Do what I did for the
first 30 years of my life.
Build a business that
allows you to afford one.
(laughs)
- That's good advice.
- I think this, Shira, I think
a lot of people forget
about my narrative because
of my spiel in this genre.
I spent the first
15, 16 years of my life
building an actual
wine retail business
before I even said
one word to the world
about my business thoughts.
I didn't come out the
womb and say I'm an influencer.
I built an actual business
and then I talked
about building businesses.
- [Shira] But the platforms
weren't there yet, right?
It evolved as your--
- That probably helped
me in some ways.
But yeah, because
they weren't there.
And by the way, they were there.
So a lot of people here,
there's a lot of OGs in here,
blogging was very
real in 2002, three, four.
I passed on that
because I'm not good at writing
and if you can't write,
you're not gonna be
successful in blogging.
And so the thing I
tell everybody in this room
and people watching at home,
self-awareness is a
big part of this as well.
You have to know
what you're good at
and what you're not good at.
The amount of people
that have started video shows
'cause they hear
video marketing is good
but they're scared to
be in front of a camera
and they're awkward,
that's just not a good strategy.
It's not your normal place.
You have to know yourself.
And so even though
the mediums were there,
I could have been a blogger,
I just knew that i couldn't
communicate very effectively
in the writing
format and so I punted it,
kept building a business, and
then when short form Twitter,
when video for YouTube came out,
I'm like, that I think I can do,
and that's what I jumped into.
- You talk about
hustle all the time, right?
At what point in the hustle,
if it's just not working,
do you say maybe I needa
move in another direction?
- [Gary] That's hard.
When to tell somebody
to quit off of their dream
or what they wanna
do is very difficult,
'cause the reality is
it coulda been the next day
that something
good could have happened
and you just jumped off.
At the same token,
I equate it to
American Idol rehearsals
where people really
think they're great at singing
and they suck shit.
I think that there's a
lot of people who think
if they just keep doing
it they're gonna break out
and be a micro-celebrity,
and they're not going to
'cause they
don't have the talent.
I think that's a very
personal answer, Shira.
I don't think I have the answer
even if I really know somebody.
It's a very difficult one,
that's one that I don't think
I'm in a position to answer.
- First time Gary
does not have an answer.
- I don't answer most things.
For people that follow
me, I stay very narrow,
very deep in my lanes.
I don't know most things.
What I do know is
attention of end consumer.
what you're up to,
what you're not gonna do
and what you're gonna do,
and that's what I trade on and
that's a good place to play.
- [Shira] So speaking of that,
what are people doing now?
What are people wanting?
What does everybody
have to take notice of now?
Where's Gary playing?
- This is a mobile-only
world, in my opinion.
Here's what I mean by that.
When I trade attention,
nothing's dead.
Billboards aren't dead,
radio's not dead,
television consumption's
not dead.
It's the advertising behind them
that you wanna drive
your business results
that needs to be debated.
What's overpriced
and what's underpriced?
I think the number
one bet in marketing today
is buying a
Super Bowl commercial.
I think it is the
number one deal in the world.
I think it's
grossly underpriced,
every person in here
will know the 30
second story of that brand
whether they watch it on YouTube
or during the Super Bowl,
and it's an incredible bargain.
At the same token, I think
the number one worst deal
in marketing today is
buying programmatic banner
and pre-roll
ads on the exchanges
and justifying
digital spend on CPM costs.
Because nobody in
here's paying attention to them
and we're pouring
ungodly amounts of money to it.
So that you would
say wait a minute,
Gary's not a digitalist,
he's a traditionalist.
I'm not, I'm going very narrow.
I think iHeartRadio live
read radio ads
by the jockey who's
running that station
is an incredible bargain.
Radio!
Meanwhile I think
that back to television,
I think the Oscars
are the most overpriced ad
at $2 million a spot because
we want that, as marketers,
to be the Super Bowl
but it's not.
The sport of watching
commercials during the Oscars
is nowhere close to the sport
of watching commercials
during the Super Bowl.
So for me, it's mobile only.
Mobile is the only
place where there's true,
besides Super Bowl,
underpriced attention.
You've gotta be
very narrow within that.
I'm obsessed.
I think everybody
in here will regret
not spending more money on
Facebook ads during this period
because the average $6 to
$14 CPMs that you see today
are gonna be 50, 60,
$70 in four to five years,
and everybody's gonna cry.
There's people that think
Facebook ads are over right now,
that are just non-practitioners.
This is back to my opening line.
There are people in
this room that have opinions
on VR, on AI, on Alexa Voice,
on Snapchat ads, on Facebook ads
and they've never
executed in those environments.
I think it's massively
important to be the architect
and to be the
plumber and to be the mason,
and I think that's
what's lacking, Shira.
And something
I've always relied on,
which is I'm
trying to be strategic,
but I'm executing my shit daily.
Biggest reason I'd
build a person brand
is so I use Instagram,
Snapchat, musical.ly,
Facebook, Twitter every day,
every feature, every time.
It keeps me a strong strategist
'cause I'm in my shit,
not pontificating on TechCrunch.
- [Shira] There you go.
That deserves an
applause, come on.
(audience applause)
So what platforms are
you excited about right now?
You are everywhere.
- [Gary] Facebook.
- Yeah, Facebook.
- [Gary] I'm heavily
excited about Facebook.
I'm excited about Snapchat
because everybody thinks
that it's over
'cause Instagram's stories,
and yet there's
tons of attention there
and the marketplace
to buy filters there
is $5 an hour for
20,000 square feet.
If you're a smart
marketer, buying filters
on the open marketplace
in Snapchat right now
could be remarkable if
you care to sell to people
under 35 years old.
Influencers on
those two platforms.
iHeartRadio, weirdly enough.
Live read by the jockey,
not the ads in the radio.
- Digital radio networks,
that just--
- No, no, no, no, no.
- Just iHeartRadio?
- [Gary] iHeartRadio.
No, no, let's go more specific.
When the jockey that
runs the station live reads.
These are the
nuances that I watch
and I watch them,
for people in the room,
not on internal modeling mixes
that justify spend behavior
in Fortune 500 companies,
but based on
actual transaction data,
if stuff is actually selling,
if donations are
actually being made.
That's another important part
that we should be
spending more time on.
There are people that
literally justify behavior
based on views and
likes and following count
and that is just, that lacks--
- [Shira] So what do
you justify, engagement--
- Sales.
- Sales?
- Selling shit, Shira.
- Yeah, you wanna make money.
- Well, yes, I wanna make money.
And anybody's who's getting paid
to help a business
wants to make money.
Like Comcast wants to
sign people fuckin' up.
They're not there to
feel good about themselves.
This is fuckin' business,
what the fuck is
everybody talking about?
(laughter)
- Yeah, you could be a
capitalist hippie, neo-hippie.
- Listen, I love
hippies but like...
The reality is if
you're talking about business,
you're talking about business.
If you're talking about
raising money for the PTA,
that's your goal.
Everybody has a goal.
Running for office,
bringing awareness
to the family that
lived next door to you
whose house burned down.
You can go very noble,
you can go very vain.
Having more fans.
You could be whatever you want,
but the one thing that ties
every person in this room with
is that we're all
fighting for the attention
of the end user.
Before you tell me
how great your service is
and why yours is
better than Amazon's
or your sneaker's
cooler than Adidas',
you need my attention.
And we're pouring
hundreds of billions of dollars
into places that no
longer have the attention.
- [Shira] All right, so lastly,
we're wrapping this up,
advice for people that
are starting new companies.
Maybe they can't be buying
tons on Facebook or boosting.
How are people supposed
to be heard this day and age
with now big
publishers coming in playing?
It's harder, you know?
- [Gary] First and foremost,
patience.
Startups lack patience.
Everybody wants
everything tomorrow.
It's gonna take
three, four, five, six years
of you working eight,
nine, ten, fifteen hours a day
before something
interesting can happen.
Just 'cause you wanna be an
influencer in snowboarding,
nobody else wants you to be.
So first and foremost, you
have to actually have talent.
That's another thing.
If you're a startup,
your product has to be good.
Let me promise
everybody in this room,
and I know a lot of
people in this room.
The greatest
marketing of all time,
if I'm lucky enough to
produce the greatest marketing
campaign and
execution of all time,
if the product
that that marketing
is deployed against
is shit, you've lost.
First of all your
startup has to be good.
Is it valuable?
If you're just starting,
are you bringing value?
Second, you have to
persevere and produce--
You know how lucky
small companies are now?
We have distribution.
Be a practitioner,
know that when you post
a piece of content--
So many people come up to be
and say Gary, it's so hard.
I look at their Instagram
and they're not posting
any of their
content with hashtags,
which is a by accident
way to pick up exposure
in a world where
they have no money.
When I took over
my dad's business
I did $3 million a year,
10% gross profit.
$300,000 before expenses.
My first year
marketing budget was $14,000.
When you have no money,
and I built that business
from a $3 to a $60 million
business in five years.
I had to make
every penny perfect.
So I was right about
email marketing in '96
and because of that
I had 91% open rates.
When Google AdWorks come
out, the day it came out,
I paid five cents
a click for words
before anybody bid me up,
and I was super
right and that worked.
- [Shira] How much is that
luck versus preparation,
and do you every
get anything wrong?
What do you do
when you make a mistake?
- I get everything wrong,
it's just that I can't recall it
'cause once it's wrong I'm
moving onto the next thing.
Dwelling on
what you fucked up on
is the quickest way for the
next thing not to work, right?
(audience applause)
I think I do everything--
You know this, this
is a fun thing to say,
some people in
the back know this,
I was a breakout YouTube
star in the first year, 2006.
I decided that the right
strategy was to leave YouTube
completely and go to Viddler
because Viddler offered me
equity in their company and
I've left an enormous amount
of attention, I deviated
from my attention thesis
to do short term economics
and equity in a company,
and I lost, I lost.
When DRock finally came
in my life two years ago
and we started to try
to build up my YouTube
for the first time, I was
sitting on 40,000 followers
in a world where
I could have had millions
if I'd just stayed the course.
So I make mistakes all the time.
I'm re-org'ing
VaynerMedia every day
'cause it's based on a
mistake I made the prior year.
I just don't give a
fuck about my mistakes.
Everybody else
cares about your mistakes.
If you're worried
about your own mistakes,
you've already lost.
- That's awesome, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- You're welcome.
- Gary, that's a great way
for us to leave it off.
- Awesome.
- You're amazing.
- I love you.
- Gary Vaynerchuk, everyone!
- Thank you guys.
(audience applause)
- Remember to share this
video on Facebook.
Gary, you better be sharing
this video on Facebook after.
- I will, I will,
we're doing all good stuff.
- We're closing this up.
And stay tuned
for more right here
from the Comcast
Social Media Lounge.
- Oh, I have free books.
- And check out his books.
And where is the books online
for people who
are watching live?
- No, I don't wanna shill, but
for you guys, there's books.
(Shira laughs)
- Google it.
All right, bye.
- Great to see you.
("Karma" by Jura Kez)